job search and the reason I picked this
topic is I I talked to many Udacity
students throughout the week and I feel
like one common thing that happens and
it doesn't matter if you are someone
very mature in your career and you
you've been through your PhD and you've
been working for years or someone who's
just getting started in the job market
really knowing how to take on that job
search and to be efficient is really
really hard and unless you've done it
before and even if you have done it
before things change technology changes
on how we do it how to make ourselves
the most efficient so I wanted to put
together a framework so that you felt
really like you could kickstart your
search and come really organized and
making the best use of your time whether
you have a lot of time in the day
because maybe you're not working right
now or if you're working and taking your
destiny course and trying to find time
to also look for a job that can get
pretty hard so the more organized we are
the more focused we are the easier it's
going to be so just a little bit about
me I have a slam a career coach I'm also
a corporate trainer I've worked in
finance consulting international
business and have dealt with a lot of
remote work myself and with other people
lived and worked in America where I'm
from also Australia China and Singapore
I specialized in career coaching
communication skills and presentation
skills so I want you to have a little
fun with me now and imagine we're going
on a road trip and let's just say we're
gonna go about 3,000 miles on this road
trip what do we need for this road trip
tell me a little bit about what you
think we need ah my answer popped up how
did that happen I hope not everybody saw
it
I am trying to look for the chat box and
for some reason it's not being very
helpful for me so I'm gonna try to get
that while I can but if we think about
going on a road trip I'm gonna drive
3,000 miles which is essentially you
know probably get somewhere near New
York all the way out to California and
if I'm getting ready to do this road
trip well the first thing I think I
might want is a destination and the
second thing I might want is a GPS so we
really would never start a road trip and
maybe unless we were about 19 and
decided to get in the car and we were in
college and gonna go do something fun
and spontaneous but most the time if
we've decided to take a 3,000 mile trip
we're gonna make sure we know our
destination we want to know where we're
headed and we definitely want to know
how we're gonna get there so whether
it's a map or your GPS you're gonna have
an idea of how you're gonna get there so
we want to think about as we look at the
job search we want to think about it a
bit as a road trip all right so we want
to start with the destination and we
went it that means to have to begin with
the end in mind and you might have heard
this phrase before begin with the end of
mine begin with the end in mind and I'm
going to show you a quote from a book
here in just a second and one thing I
want as we think about begin with the
end in mind it's when if we talk about
the end it's not it's not the dream job
you're gonna have in 20 30 years it's
not something that you're aiming for
down the road but we went we're really
looking for where's that next step where
is that next stop on our journey where's
that destination on the road trip so if
you haven't seen it before her Stephen
Covey I'm sure many of you are familiar
he wrote the seven Habits of Highly
Effective People and he says to begin
with the end in mind means to start with
a clear understanding of your
destination it means to know where
you're going so you better understand
where you are now so the steps you take
are always in the right direction
and I know you know think about yourself
if you've been overwhelmed on a project
or your job search or it's something
else in your job or school if you don't
think about what you're trying to
achieve first we can spin a lot of
wheels we can waste a lot of time
heading in the wrong direction now it
doesn't mean that sometimes there are
some exploratory stages where we're
trying to figure out where we're headed
and those things can change but really
when we know that there's the this point
we want to get to this goal we have in
mind this destination we can feel a lot
more confident so that's where we're
gonna kind of start our framework so our
agenda today we're gonna begin with the
end in mind we're gonna talk more about
that we're gonna go through your
application materials checklists which
is really important to keep focused on
throughout the entire job search and in
that we're also gonna look at how you
dasa tea can help you we're gonna touch
on some organizational tools to get you
started
I just heard a beef welcome to whoever's
joining us now we're just getting
started with our agenda here and today
we're gonna kind of go through phase one
of these organizational tools and then
we'll be following up with another
webinar where we get a little deeper on
how to organize the job search remember
today's the kick start is to help you
get a bit of a framework and start
setting some goals and lastly we're
gonna open it up for Q&A so begin with
the end in mind you want to know the job
you are targeting that is your
destination now you might have a few
different jobs you're considering you
might have 15 different job titles that
could be a possibility especially if
you're working in data science the data
scientist data analysts know out there
when you look for jobs that there's a
lot of inconsistencies on job titles so
when we know when we're talking about
that destination and that job you're
targeting that doesn't mean it's so tiny
that it's one exact company with one one
exact job title as you search you're
gonna be searching around that all those
parameters but
having a nice clear target can help you
build those parameters out and as you
get more comfortable understanding those
parameters you might decide you know
what I really thought I was going for
this job title but the more I look these
parameters are kind of taking me into
this space over here that's a little bit
different title but because I had that
focus I have that job I was targeting I
was able to identify that if I didn't
have that job I was targeting the very
beginning I would have could have been
all over that dartboard which is what I
usually am if I ever try to throw a dart
but in real life I try to have a little
more focus where I have control right so
some of you might be thinking so you're
saying I have to know my ultimate dream
job right now absolutely not remember
this can be a stepping stone it can be
the next stop on the journey can be this
stop on the road trip maybe you say you
know what my 3,000 miles that's to me
that's a little hard to look at right
now I'm gonna go 500 right now this is
the job I want right now but I'm gonna
know what it is know what I'm targeting
and remember it can be flexible targets
can move if someone had told me ten
years ago that this was the job I would
have and I had that focus I would not
have known where they came up with it
there's a lot of steps along the way and
sometimes those paths are quite curvy
some people have a much straighter path
there's no right or wrong there's no
perfect path the most important thing is
is that again you have the goal you have
the focus but you have that agility and
flexibility along the way
have you ever taken a road trip and just
seeing something really interesting
exciting off the side of the road you
see a sign for something and you just
decide to like pop off and maybe take a
little detour that can happen in your
job search too but still having that you
get back on the highway and you keep
going so begin with the end in mind how
do you do it how do you find that job
that you want as the destination how do
you figure it out a few things here and
we're going to go through each of these
very very closely and clearly one is
some research job descriptions sounds
very basic very simple we're going to
talk a little bit about how to do that
and how you can select a few ideal we're
gonna call it next to jobs because at
this stage you know maybe you have your
sights set on being a senior director
level of being a on a development team
but that might not be the job you're
looking for right now it's good to know
that focus in the future when we talk
about researching real job descriptions
we're looking at that next ideal job
what's next and as you look at those
we're going to look at prioritizing and
analyzing the key factors that come up
with each job and I'll show you what
those key factors are this presentation
is being recorded so feel free to take
notes but also it will be posted on our
YouTube channel so you want to go back
to it later and just like sit back and
chill right now and listen that's fine
too so when you research a job
description number one thing is to look
beyond the title first as we talked
about there's some big industry
discrepancy in discrepancies where the a
title that one company means something
very different in another company or the
title in one department of a company it
looks very different than a title
somewhere else else so don't get caught
up on job title don't get caught up on a
seniority or a title as you're looking
focus more on keywords and multiple
searches so if I'm looking for a job in
digital marketing I'm gonna use a lot of
the keywords that I know are out there
that I like to do maybe I'm I really
like the search engine optimization so
I'm gonna look for that term and maybe
I'm gonna look for digital marketer I'm
new so I'm gonna maybe look for
something that has entry level or junior
in the title and really like expanding
my search so I mean as I'm researching
and figuring out what job it is my
target job I'm understanding more and
more about what's out there
and doing the quick scan again I I think
a lot of times people can get stuck
right here at this stage researching the
job descriptions because they get caught
up on analyzing especially many of you
analytical people in the crowd and
looking to detail to every single little
requirement we're going to talk about
how you can do a quick scan so know if
you kind of put it in the yes pile or
you throw it out and it's a really
important skill to pick up and the more
job descriptions you're reading if
you're doing that you know if you spend
a week researching descriptions by next
week you're quick scan is gonna go so
quick because you know exactly what
you're looking for you also start to
learn that certain companies fill their
job descriptions with way too much
content a lot of times I've talked to
recruiters that say you know they might
be hiring let's say for a let's just use
digital marketer and they've talked to
four different managers in the company
and all those managers had input into
this job description and what they're
looking for that ends up being a really
big list of qualifications and and
skills they're looking for where in
reality you probably don't have to meet
every single one of those we're gonna
talk about that quick scan so quick scan
I'm researching the Job Description I'm
gonna ask myself three questions I'm
gonna look at it really quickly like
with under a minute
and based on my first glance am i
confident I can do the job I mean if I
if me personally if I was reading a web
development Job Description right now
I'd pretty quickly know I cannot do that
job I am NOT confident now I
might look at a job description for me
for a corporate trainer or a career
coach and I'd say I'm confident I can do
the job
next is looking at the Rick the absolute
requirements and do I feel like I meet
about 75% of those now again this is all
proximate we're doing a quick quick look
I look down those requirements if I feel
like I meet about 75% give or take
then I'm feeling good and the last thing
I want to do is think what do I like
about it at a quick glance did I like
the company did I like the some of the
work they were describing did I like how
I felt the path could go for me like
really quickly ask yourself these three
questions if it's you know yes and yes
and the last question there was
something you found you liked about it
then put that in your yes pile you're
gonna come back to those later and when
I say yes pile
sometimes on LinkedIn indeed a lot of
the sites you can save them or star them
or give them a heart so that you can
come back to those later but when you're
doing the research getting through a lot
I find and I know other people have
found success and looking as many job
descriptions as they can pretty quickly
like chunking this together like hey I'm
gonna do this over the next four days
next week whatever you need go through
50 to 100 descriptions but remember
they're quick it's only gonna take you
two hours it's a really a quick process
for this step and by the time you've
looked at 25 30 50 you start really
getting a feel for what you do like and
what you don't
and what especially when it's in your
field you understand that you start
understanding more of the terminology
and descriptions they're using for the
work that you can look at it quickly and
go oh I hate this part of the job and it
looks like it's pretty much all you're
doing I'm getting it out of there so
take this quick scan then hopefully if
you've looked at 50 descriptions and
maybe you get it down to about 10 and
then we're gonna see what you do next
so we're gonna look at all the different
factors and we want to prioritize these
and analyze these and for each one
you'll be thinking what is ideal to me
and what's acceptable and what's not
acceptable obviously and I was going
through this with a client recently and
they said why do you always put
compensation at the bottom the reason I
put compensation at the bottom is
because usually you don't know at this
stage right you don't know by looking at
job descriptions they're not gonna tell
you typically what the pay is so I think
it's important to put on here because I
think it's an important thing to think
about at some stages in our life and in
our career compensation needs to be the
most important thing sometimes we're
fortunate that it doesn't need to be the
most important thing but usually we know
the range we want to be in so it's good
to have some focus there but for the
most part when you're prioritizing and
it's important to know like hey listen
I'm at a time in my life or my
circumstances that compensations needs
to be number one I need to know I'm
gonna be able to pay my bills and and do
what I need to do to you know provide
for myself and my family so know where
that priority lies so that you keep that
in focus everything else really is are
things that you're going to be
dissecting from each job as you look
through them
so we're gonna go through each one of
these and think about some of the things
you want to think about as you're
analyzing these job descriptions so
again let's imagine you've done your
quick scan you're down to about five or
ten descriptions that you really like
that really speak to you and and this
might be something you're doing two
months before you're really applying for
jobs these might be job descriptions
you're just using to help give you a
vision and motivation and to help you
analyze what you're looking for they may
not be the exact job you're gonna apply
for tomorrow or next week so think about
the title does it sound too junior to
senior like what what is the feeling you
get from it what is the feeling about
where you think you should be or what
you need to be what's the function of
the job is it exactly what you're
looking for is it similar to something
you've done before is it too similar
that you feel like it's a lateral move
is it too advanced and you feel like
maybe you're out of your comfort zone
look at the skills they're looking for
are they the skills that you're
confident in you'd like to use and you
want to use if it says Python's number
one and you just started learning Python
and it looks like it's a huge part of
the job maybe that's not the exact part
now if you've been building your Python
skills and it's what you want to do
every day and you'd like to do every day
maybe that's better aligned for you
what's the industry is it something I
like and I know and I believe in if I
was looking at a job in digital
marketing for a let's just say a air
airline and I completely disagree with
the way airlines run their business and
I don't agree with the emissions and
that's probably not a good fit for me
right but if it's something or maybe
industry is not really it doesn't matter
to me I just love to do marketing and it
really I'm not as hung up on what
industry it's in but know how you feel
about certain industries is it something
you really like that you know that you
believe in sometimes when people pivot
careers like that in health care and
maybe pharmaceutical sales for a while
then they've gone into
development and software development and
they want to move into that field but
they stay in healthcare pharmaceuticals
because they know a lot of the lingo
they understand the business what's the
organization some people are attracted
to startup some people don't like that
uncertainty that comes along the large
corporates something you like something
you don't try to figure out what you
prefer how important it is to you also I
put in their consulting companies
meaning a lot of times if you're in tech
you're working for an outside consulting
company and you're contracting in is
that something that appeals to you or
something you would rather not be
involved with and understanding what
takes place in each of these location
obviously can be super important at
times is it something that you're
willing to relocate for is it a job do
you want to be able to have some
flexibility work from home is it only
remote and last the compensation again
you may not know this but research it
and know where you're comfortable and
what you'd want your potential to be so
those are the different functions that
you want to analyze as you look at these
jobs the next really great stuff to take
is to create your ideal next job and I'm
going to pause here for just a second
and see if anyone has questions and you
can type those in the chat about where
we are so far in these areas that we're
looking at
as you think about the job description
or any questions so far as we're going
along don't see anything popping up so I
might just go back to the presentation
mode all right yes yeah so today we are
we're talking about getting ready for
the job search and organizing your job
search and helping you prepare sorry can
you say that again is it about the I
mean the good to go the job search or
this is about the experience well it
could be really any stage in your career
it's really to help you take on the
organization part of the job search
whether you've been working for 20 years
and you're looking for your next job or
if you kind of just come out of school
and looking for your first job this
organization on this research and the
the tools that we're talking about could
really help you at any stage oh yeah
I feel very good yeah okay
okay great Thanks so then the next step
I would write this down one to seven and
order those first remember prioritize
what's most important to you is it
compensation is the skills you're gonna
be using it's that the industry you're
in what type of organization are you
very set on working for a very specific
company order those prioritize those how
you feel like what is most important to
you and remember there's no right or
wrong location for some people could be
absolute number one they cannot move
there with their family they're settled
they will not move for someone else that
could be the bottom of the list they
don't care where they go so this is your
personal ideal next job again remember
this is all about creating a focus and a
vision for you
so why do you have it so you can have a
vision so you can have that focus and so
you can have a targeted search I think a
lot of times we're lucky because you
know we can find so many jobs online
right at our fingertips but there are so
many sources and so many places to look
that it does get overwhelming and just
like if you know if I'm searching to buy
something online and you can spiral out
and get get up suddenly you're like
eight websites later and you don't know
why you're looking at something you're
looking at same thing happens in the job
search so keeping this ideal job that
remember you've researched the different
jobs and it's almost like you can say
okay I really like that the title here
and the description here and the the
skills they're using here to help me
have a vision of what I want I'm gonna
put it up on my bulletin board I'm gonna
look at it and focus on that when I do
my search I'm gonna have that targeted
search now remember your targeted search
if this is your ideal job and it's here
you're gonna expand that gradually and
that is okay and that's what you should
be doing but if you don't start with a
pretty strong focus it's really hard to
go beyond that into the in the right
realm of possibilities but remember
targets
can change don't get too stuck on it
either don't feel like you know what I
really wanted to work for Google and I'm
just not getting responses I'm I can't
seem to get in the door but and that's
all I wanted
sometimes you have to change those
targets and sometimes you know maybe
you're gonna go work some us for a while
and maybe that job at your dream company
will come later but the agile be
flexible and know that your targets can
change so how do you get there at this
point now you said you know we're on
that road trip we know where we're going
but now we need that GPS we need the
tools and the organization to figure out
how to get that job how to start getting
interviews so as we navigate the job
search first we're going to talk about a
little bit about your application
materials resume and so forth and then
we're going to talk about some search
routines and I'm going to give you a
daily goal worksheet that you can work
with and adapt however you like
so we think about application materials
I put github separately because I know
github is not relevant to every job
seeker LinkedIn resume and cover letter
should be absolutely relevant to every
job seeker these are most important for
every job applicant github for you know
if it's you you know if you're coding
that's an important place for you to be
making sure you have those updated
materials um as most of you probably
know we have Udacity projects for all of
those so you can go in and do a LinkedIn
project a resume project and cover
letter when you go on to the site it
will say do you want to submit or get
started you can hit that and go through
it at your you know you could do it in
an hour you can do it over two weeks you
don't actually have to submit until
you're ready and if you can go through
it's kind of like a tutorial like a
course you're gonna get videos and tips
and guidelines and you can start
creating your LinkedIn or resume cover
letter and then submit it when you're
ready for a review github the same so
you've got Udacity projects don't be
afraid to ask some peers to review it I
know when I've looked for a job and I've
had friends and colleagues looking for
jobs and asking each other to to take a
look at our resumes or LinkedIn get some
feedback especially people in your field
if if you're a developer and you've got
seven friends who are also developers
say hey take a look at my resume what do
you think can you look at my github give
me some feedback don't be afraid to do
that and then obviously get your coach
input Udacity you get one-to-one
coaching sessions if you haven't had one
already you get four within 12 months of
finishing your nano degree so you can
start those at any time and I do a lot
of LinkedIn especially LinkedIn resume
cover letter github we we keep that with
the reviewers and the more technical
people
I have glanced at github and I have to
admit I don't understand it so much so
the other three on the other side we can
help you with a lot
now I want to talk a little bit about
what I have developed for a lot of my
clients to help them with their job
search on a daily basis and as you can
see here well and I was looking at my
desk I'm kind of obsessed with to-do
lists and stationery and I've got like a
notepad here that I've bought that gives
me all these different things to look
for and I've got another one here and
you know obviously I like to get them in
colorful arrays to keep myself motivated
and write down what I'm doing for the
day we apply for a job and I've looked
for different organ I've researched a
ton about what's out there to help
people get organized and it's there's
not a lot and I think I'm gonna walk you
through this and I'm going to show a
sample of one that I've used and this
could be something that you do daily
some people like to do it by the week
after this session if you would like
this sent to you in Excel I'll be happy
to send it it's not rocket science but
it does really help people stay
organized so obviously just setting some
daily goals or weekly goals writing down
those jobs you've applied for so you can
see what you've done
interview prep all along through the job
search process you should be thinking
about what interview questions you could
practice if people just thought of one
interview question a day and thought
about how they would answer it write the
answer out type it out read it rehearse
it feel confident about it the is a
great thing to be doing consistently I
know a lot of people who have gone
through and they've taken kind of one
step at a time like I came to do my
resume this week and then I do my
Linkedin and then I do this and okay now
I want to apply for jobs but I haven't
thought about interviewing that
interview prep can be all the time think
about a question at a to questions a day
on the right you see where we're looking
at those application materials here you
might in your notes you might say on the
resume need to update most recent job or
need to tweak the education section
because you finished your LinkedIn or
sorry you finish your Udacity course
whatever it might be that you know I've
heard people say for every job you apply
for
look at your resume again is there
something you can edit
even if you have had a professional
prepare it and you've edited and the
coaches looked at it there's always that
the fresh eyes on a document like that
do a little tweaking
now again I'm part of what we talked
about and the reason we're having this
is to help you be efficient so one thing
I want to mention on resume is don't
revamp it for every job description for
every job application if you want to
tweak it a little always read through it
what if you what if you had a typo that
you never caught me for do a quick read
make sure it looks good put it in a
fresh PDF date it so you know you've
really checked on it and if one thing I
find that people try to do is they try
to rework so much to match the job
they're looking for and I think that can
get very cumbersome and if you're trying
to tailor it too much it can lead to a
lot more mistakes and definitely a lot
of inefficiencies LinkedIn same thing
check it every once in awhile you know
maybe on here you'll say for LinkedIn
that you're gonna do the career project
or you have you're gonna go in today and
update your About section github is kind
of an ongoing as you all know maybe
there's something new you can load in
you've worked on before maybe you want
to go and clean it up a bit
cover letter cover letter it's like a
whole different topic we could have a
webinar on and we probably will soon and
I get a lot of questions about cover
letters in my opinion a cover letter can
help put you in the game put you in the
running for a job the most important
thing is that you take the time to write
a cover letter that really if you've got
that dream job that dream next job that
ideal job we should say that we've
outlined right you know what you're
targeting right a cover letter to that
fictitious job if you need to apply to
it so that you know what's your story
how are you explaining why you're a good
fit why you're a good candidate why they
should hire you and in that cover letter
if it's if you have that's where having
that job target also helps because
you're writing a cover letter for that
job and as you apply for a very similar
so you should be able to go back to that
cover letter and just do some little bit
of tweaking and getting your
applications out the door again it's all
about this efficiency and the next is
having the networking activities it
can't just all be sitting at your
computer applying for jobs we need to
have some networking activities people
were talking to emailing phoning having